what's up everyone welcome back to the
cider interview Studio it's Sundance
20124 I am lucky to be sitting with the
team behind the documentary sub bird in
the clutch congratulations on the film I
was so happy that I wound up getting a
sign to this interview big fan of yours
for a very long time thank you so first
before we begin our conversation we have
to give a special shout out to filo our
wonderful sponsor who lets us be here in
Park City celebrating independent film
filo is breaking barriers by putting the
power to greenl films in the hands of
creators and fans if you want to learn
more about filo and their Community
check out their website
film. all right Sarah you're first up on
my list here sometimes the Internet
isn't accurate so I'll ask you this
first actually this is your feature
directorial debut right that's right
okay why make that move with a
documentary and what was it about Sue
Story that you thought would best suit
your skill set and how you wanted to you
know show show your world show the world
your craft as a feature
filmmaker that's a big
question um well it's a documentary
because that's the space that I've been
making films in for the last decade um I
was lucky enough to be um uh brought
this film by The Producers by by Jay and
um you know when I started researching
Sue and her career and everything that
she has done um as an athlete but also
her on the game and her contribution to
women's sports um I just fell in love
with it I was really inspired by the
story um you know we got uh quite a lot
of rejection at the beginning of trying
to get this movie made and I think that
just set a fire off in me where I was
just the more NOS I heard the more yes
my brain said this is the right story to
make I was reading that in the Press
notes that is absolutely wild to me that
you face so much rejection right at the
gate it I mean feels like a no-brainer
it I mean it did to me um and you know
we felt we had a really strong story and
um a lot to bring to the table and
getting financing for any film is never
a no-brainer but given the the interest
in sports and male Sports docs that are
out there in the space we knew that
there was an audience for it so we felt
like we were bringing a very very high
quality product to the table and to just
kind of be met with that you know
resistance you know just just felt like
it was shocking but it also I think just
you know reignited you know all of our
passion to tell this story well standing
your ground on this and making it happen
will probably make less people
experience that rejection in the future
so thank you for doing that I hope so
Jay a question for you because I know
you're producing a lot now but I believe
this is your first time producing a
documentary so two questions about that
first one were you interested in making
a documentary or was it specific to
Sue's story did her story uh inspire you
to get into this realm no I mean it's a
little bit of both but really this was
Sue Story I think um you know my
producing partner um Aaron Bergman you
know we have a production company black
Mar MIT we always talk about we love
taking worlds people think they know
tilting them on their axis and showing
you that world from a different point of
view and for us Sue's story was like
exactly that we think we know women's
basketball but we don't really a because
there's not enough storytelling there's
not enough there's not enough
opportunities out there for women who
play in the league to get out and and
control their own narratives and tell
their own stories um and then there's
this other piece of like the knowledge
that we really have of the WNBA kind of
comes through this NBA lens I mean they
a lot of the marketing that we've seen
in the past for example and even some of
the deals and stuff are often formatted
um from the NBA to WNBA in the past
again Sue can speak to to a lot of those
changes but we were like oh that's
really how we know it so what if we take
someone like Sue who has had this
legendary rockar badass amazing career
and like give her the mic right and let
her tell her own St be a part of telling
her own story and in doing that she's
also telling the story of of the WNBA
and of women's basketball and of women's
sports at large to some degree um so it
really was SU story that really really
just like sparked an interest for us and
made us want to jump in and actually
made us want to beg her to let us tell
her story oh yes I'm going to get to
that in a minute one more question for
you Jay what surprised you most about
what it takes to produce a documentary
feature versus a traditionally scripted
narrative um I I I don't think anything
surprised me I've just been I've been a
part of some Doc stuff before and I've
done some Doc siries so nothing I don't
think anything surprised me I think it's
back to what Sarah spoke to though was
um the amount of rejection that we got
on this when we took it out um and I
will never forget us being on the phone
we were on a zoom actually with Sue and
she's like listen if you guys don't sell
it like I get it like it's hard like we
you know this is we scream from the
mountains like we have the product we
are here we are entertaining people are
showing up and still we don't get the
opportunities and I just remember this
fire that was lit for all of us for our
entire team this fire was lit of like
first of all we're not letting Sue down
second of all we're going to tell this
story and even if we got the NOS that we
got across town you know who you are um
even if we got those NOS we were going
to make those people come back we were
going to go find the money for this dock
make this Dock and make all those people
come back on the back end like that's
how we all felt about it I love the
thought of the nose going and seeing the
movie and being like I'll be
there'll be mess that up yeah I like
that attitude um Emily for you now I
know you have a pretty significant
amount of documentary producing
experience how are you able to apply
that experience to this film and maybe
what expertise could you offer in terms
of how best to shape Sue's story into a
narrative format a documentary format
yeah that's a great question I think for
us we really early on wanted to map out
there's so much you could tell about
Sue's story right and so many themes
that you can expand upon just looking at
her story we knew from the start we had
early on in meetings we were you know
there's so many ways to tell it but it
made a lot of sense that we were
tracking Sue's final year and to use
that as our spine um as kind of a Tik
Tok to get us through the story and then
as we could as we moved through that we
could get into the other themes of her
story of um coming into the WNBA very
early on in a completely different
league and as she grew she helped the
league grow and we really wanted to
follow that trajectory through her story
um I think what is so tempting when
you're following somebody who's so
Dynamic who's so exciting to watch and
in such an exciting World there are
daytoday it's like well God she's doing
this amazing thing like should we film
that and we just really had to continue
to come back to the story what is the
story we're telling and what is it that
we really need in order to tell it and
she obviously you know the physicality
of being an athlete
is only one aspect a lot of it is the
focus and we really were cognizant of
only taking the time that we needed um
to tell that story and not get in the
way of of her focus and what she was
there to do soon now that we've talked
around you for five minutes can you tell
me a little bit about what you thought
about like the team of people at this
table and also the people who were
involved that aren't here today that
gave you the confidence that these are
the people I should trust with my story
yeah a big part of it was um a good
friend of mine Ryan ruko who is an ESPN
announcer essentially the voice of the
WNBA is really good friends with Aaron
Jay's partner also friends with Jay so
immediately there was a trust right
because I trust Ryan and Ryan was kind
of the the Connecting Point there and um
from from that point on there was a
pitch where it was just me Jay Aaron my
agent at the time um just listening you
know I was just listening but I trusted
I trusted already so um I think a female
athlete in this world you can get a
little jaded at times you know you you
do hear a lot of nose and it can be
really tiresome and it can feel
rejecting and dejecting and you have to
find the energy to get back up all the
time but here was a scenario where I
really trusted it I didn't feel like
that was going to be be the case um and
obviously they proved me right so it
allowed um for me to show up as myself
and for I think all of us to to get a
really great Dock done so you trusted
them but was there any spe specific
thing that maybe made you think like we
can do this together but I need to make
sure that you know this layer of my
experience is in the spotlight in a
significant manner you know I actually
never thought of it that way um but this
pitch meeting that I'm referring to did
happen at the end of the 20120 WNBA
season um for my team we had just won
which was amazing so I was on a little
bit of a high but at the same time the
league was really stepping into its own
identity um you know for anyone that
watches a doc you see there's there is
like a trajectory of how this league has
grown I was on the same I was like
parallel pathing that in a lot of ways
which is pretty cool to see now I never
really thought of it that way until
doing this project um but that pitch
meeting happened at a time where women's
sports was really on the come up I mean
it was really starting to you know
people were taking note viewership
numbers were changing and it it really
just felt like the right time to tell my
story more than anything so all the
pieces fell together so given what you
just said and and the idea of you
running into folks telling you no it
makes me think of the the filo question
we've been uh asking because it's a
company that's all about putting the
power in the Creator's hands for any of
you whether it's a a film a show you
worked on or something in basketball can
you recall a time when someone put the
creative power in your hands when you
didn't think you were going to get
it I mean I feel like Sarah Emily should
say on this dock yeah fair enough I'm
joking I'm joking no 100% I I I would
actually agree with that because you
know I I I felt like there were so many
pivotal moments in in a in the way that
this film got made and we started in
2021 and really we were just going shoot
to shoot at that stage cuz we just
didn't know whether we could find the
money like what what was going to be the
trajectory of this you know what what
Sue was thinking and feeling in terms of
her retirement at that time so we were
really just trying to Cobble it together
um and we were still exploring
creatively will this be a series will
this be a film like what will will be
the the strongest and and most powerful
tool to tell Sue story so you know I I
feel like the the the producers and Sue
just kept giving me that trust and we
like if you're going to put the energy
in you know everyone else will be be
behind you and and vice versa so I just
felt like everyone else was doubling
down I was doubling down this felt like
Kismet to me I thought if we we all are
I don't know maybe we're dizzy and Crazy
by doing this but there's something in
that craziness that propels you to just
make the impossible um and when I would
see Sue play and and all the women um in
the W I just always felt so inspired by
what they just they just got on with it
you know they just came out they just
did this thing um and I just thought
it's this is inspirational to me if if
they can do it you know damn it I can do
it so I don't know it was a bit of The
Producers giving me that but Sue and the
the play is also you know inspiring me
beautiful answer I just want to say real
quick sorry s go ahead go ahead no no go
ahead you sure yeah we're here for you
go I want to say a big piece of that is
Waffle iron um so we should I just want
to shout out Justin biskin and his team
at Waffle iron because they are a big
big piece of that they they did Finance
this film and when we had our first
meeting with them uh by the time we got
off before we even got off the meeting
Justin's main thing that he came back to
us was like we want to empower this
creative team to tell this story in the
way that the T excuse me story needs to
be told and we are here to help you in
any way we can do that and you don't
often get that from financiers so I just
want to give a shout out to them because
they were
um very very helpful and and supporting
in this process yeah the only thing I
was going to add it's um it's actually
been one of my favorite Parts about this
process sitting here now is um I think
some of what everyone on the quote
unquote team has experienced in terms of
the nose and you know is are we going to
get it done I'm like that is the life
that is my life in women's basketball
right being told no so it's this really
I think cool Connecting Point between us
all now where you're told no you have to
find a way you're told no you have to
find another way and you're like I swear
this is good I swear people are going to
be interested I swear this I swear that
and then now you're sitting here at
Sundance and it's that moment where I've
experienced it I've been lucky enough to
experience it as an athlete where you
know maybe I'm in front of people
showing them viewership numbers of WNBA
playoffs game playoff games saying see I
told you and now we're sitting up here
at Sundance being like see I told you
and it's kind of interesting you guys
got to experience what it is to be a
female athlete how'd you like it no I'm
joking
speaking of uh of pivots and kind of you
know evolving the film on the Fly I was
wondering because originally the movie
was supposed to cover your your final
season and then it wasn't your final
season did you all have the heads up
that that was going to happen or was
that truly an on the spot decision that
you had no idea about can I just tell
you the text messages that went back and
forth about should somebody reach out to
sue should somebody ask Sue is Sue gonna
what do you think Su is going to do does
anybody know what Sue is going to do we
all there was a there was an email chain
about it there was a text chain about it
we didn't no one knew when the
appropriate time to ask was we wanted to
make sure that Sue had enough space and
respect where she was like at her in
that process um but I just remember like
all these emails and text messages going
back where like it's been two weeks
should we ask her now and everybody's
like no you just have to let her and we
did use Ryan once again Ryan ruko shout
out to Ryan who's is one of the
producers on this as well we used Ryan
as the kind of the conduit to get to get
closer to the answer um that we
ultimately got which was she wasn't
retiring and I just want to add a small
bit to that that it was after the
Olympics and um Sue had had you know won
her fifth gold medal and uh I I was you
know we have cans on and and uh you know
Sue was miked and she was talking but
there were there were words that she was
using that were future tents and I was
like wait a
minute that means does that mean what I
think it means and so I was like
messaging the the executive producers
like do we know does anyone know because
you know I'm I'm just hearing this on
the cans and I feel like maybe there's
you know there there's there's a thought
happening here that's germinating and I
don't know you you were going through it
so yeah I'm like I wish I could remember
I'm like you tell the story can you tell
the story of like sorry this is one of
my favorite things you tell the story of
how you talked to a couple of people
about their own retirements and like
what you how you should or shouldn't do
and I don't think that made the dog but
I'm just so I love that story yeah um I
became friendly well Ray Allen a yuk
Conrad I've known him forever and then I
became friendly last couple years with
um CC Sabathia and if if you know their
their stories as athletes and their
retirements totally different talk to Ry
Ry just like kind of faded into the back
his was a little bit different because
there was like a question mark around
him signing with a team even though he
hadn't played in a year so it's a little
bit different but he was very and I
talked to him and he was very much like
no like you finish your career you just
kind of go into the sunset you announce
when you're done you don't need all the
like hoopla for lack of a better I was
like yeah cuz I kind of was on that side
of the fence for a
while then I talked to Cece and CeCe was
like because he had just gone through a
retirement season where he announced and
he's like you have to do it you you have
to do it and the number one reason is
you have to do it for the fans you have
to share this moment you have to let
have to let them say goodbye to you and
I never thought of it in that way and
that really tipped the scale for me not
necessarily to come back but it may it
it did like play a role I think I still
had some basketball left so that was
really ultimately the the deciding
factor but it definitely was the reason
I decided to announce the retirement
while um my final season what ended up
being my final season was still going on
such a beautiful way to think about it
I've definitely had that with athletes
retiring but because I'm film and TV
heavy makes me think of when TV show
gets cut off too soon and then the
viewer doesn't have that sense of
closure and that's a good point it hurts
it hurts I know so that was something
that didn't make it into the Final Cut
of the documentary can you give me kind
of the opposite something that you
weren't prepared for what big of a role
it was going to play in the Finish cut
like something emerged that something
that emerged as like a pivotal point of
the story that you weren't expecting at
the
start
uh I mean first thing that comes to mind
is our initial rough cut
Yukon Sue college career was like a
featurelength film in its own right and
we were like okay how much of this story
do we really need to tell but there is a
really um pivotal moment there um with
where Sue has an injury and um she's
able to reflect on herself and and where
she's meant to head and this game and
for us we really wanted to take the time
to tell that story and I don't think any
of us were anticipating it but Yukon was
gracious they gave us boxes of VHS tapes
of DVDs of photos and we have this team
who were just taking their time you know
scanning every photo and we just had
such wonderful material home videos that
that Sue and Diana terasi had taken and
it just it just spoke to us so much that
it became a larger part than I think we
were anticipating that's such an
important part to include because I have
to imagine there's many there's many
young athletes out there who could think
it's all over when something like that
happens and to be able to see you power
through that and where you wound up it's
probably very inspiring to a lot of
people there's one thing that I would
add that was a real Discovery for me and
that was um really including Sue's
engagement with fans and the way that
Sue makes them feel because once I was
filming I couldn't help but become a fan
and I know that that's like a
documentary no no um there were there
were so many times I wanted to like high
five that performance and way to go and
you just can't help it cuz it's the
atmosphere is electric and when I would
see that that exchange and that just joy
and happiness I thought I have to get
that Joy into the film I really want to
show what that's like because it's it's
positive and it's just yeah it was a
very palpable thing when I was there and
I I I really hope that came through in
the film oh I have a followup for you
sue on that point I I pulled this quote
from the notes because I felt like it
was important to emphasize here Sarah
you said the hardest thing for me was
getting Sue to acknowledge what she's
achieved her Legacy and what she's
created for girls and for women coming
into the game behind her now that the
documentary
exists and I I'm assuming you've seen it
is that undeniable do you have to
recognize and celebrate that you did
that I never denied it I just didn't
want to say it you should say it you
should be proud of it maybe watch the
doc you'll see I give in a little bit I
give in a little bit so who's the
greatest WNBA point guard of all
time I think it's
me we love making talk about our we love
it as you should as as you should
seriously I'll end on a film specific
question for Sue because we are talking
about how many people out there you
inspire in the sports realm but I'm
curious because we're at the Sundance
Film Festival is there a film you've
seen in the past that inspired you to do
something oo great question a film I've
seen in the past that inspired me um let
me think let me think I'm like a lot of
the sports stcs um well this is really
putting me on the spot okay I have one
finally my dad took me to see hoop
dreams when it came out in like the
local theater obviously it was like a
smaller film so we had to go to like
some random theater that was like 20 30
minutes away um and it it's not
necessarily that I could see myself in
those stories it was just that these
stories were being told and my dad you
know took that moment to say like hey
there's this you know this documentary
about these two high school kids in
Chicago like let's go check it out and
it was just really it was just a really
memorable experience like I I can like
vividly remember it and feel what it
felt like to see that on the big screen
again it wasn't that I like pulled
something from it I just remember how it
made me feel I'm always here for a hoop
dreams reference always I must let you
go I will say huge congratulations on
the film and thanks for sharing some of
your experience with us to everybody out
there Sue bird in the clutch keep an eye
out for it also big thanks to filo and
stay tuned for more from sunit 2024
soon